okay chair you ready
thank you good evening everybody um it
seems like
such a long time since we've met it's i
can't believe it's
over 12 months it was january last year
when we had our last committee meeting
so i hope everybody has
managed to stay safe and to stay well
um i have apologies from
um councillor bennett who is not very
well
um and also at the moment from
councillor blackburn who is struggling
with
technology issues um
could i ask if there are any
declarations of interest at all in any
of the items this evening
hi councillor uh western i'd just like
to declare again because it's been a
year that i am a
paid teacher and a local author not in
an academy school in trafford
and i understand we don't have any
questions from members of the public
um so if we move on to the minutes of
the previous meeting which were the 14th
of january last year
is everybody too happy to accept the
minutes
as a true record of the meeting
general consensus thank you
okay i'm going to um
can i just point out i think there's an
inaccuracy in the minutes
um i think we've got um karen samples
down
as the interim director for education
whereas um she wasn't at that time she
was
the director so i think it'd just be
helpful if we couldn't have that amended
thank you certainly will and apologies
karen
okay so um i'm going to move on we have
offices with us this evening
um we have karen samples who is the
director of education
and we have claire fisher who is school
management projects
manager um we have lindsey
burage who is the virtual head teacher
for children in care
we have jill mcgregor who is the
corporate director of
children's services and we have pamela
wharton who is
director of early help and children's
social care
we also have um counsellor kath hines
um who is deputy leader of the council
and executive member for
children's services i do hope i've not
missed anybody
um so with your permission um
we're going to take what is item
six which is trafford um
score sufficiency and place planning
and i'm going to hand over to um claire
fisher and
karen samples for this report thank you
thank you thank you councillor weston
and
what we've done in that report is we've
hoped to provide a description there of
the approach that we take to the
strategic school place planning in
trafford
and just so that we can ensure the
sufficient school places
for our current and future children
living in the area
and as you've said uh councillor weston
i'm delighted to have claire fisher with
me tonight to support
um and that's in the absence of of sarah
butters
but claire heads up our capital team our
capital projects team
and she also links him with richard rowe
and the play shaping board
so claire has some really extensive
knowledge and expertise
and connections in into place planning
unfortunately we're not able to have our
admissions lead with us tonight but
again if there are any questions
with regard to admissions we're happy to
take them back and get a response to you
if we can't answer them tonight um
just to start with i just wanted to uh
kind of
um share a little bit of information
around the context of trafford actually
and currently we have um just under 42
300 children in our trafford schools
um and that spread across our 65 primary
schools our 19 secondary schools
seven special schools and two
alternative provision
and and we're delighted to say that 94
of our traffic schools are rated either
good or outstanding by usted
and and this actually is quite important
really
um because that in itself can sometimes
add to some of the pressures and
challenges in place planning
we're a very high performing authority a
very successful authority
so families want their children to
attend our trafford schools
and they move into the borough to attend
our schools and that obviously includes
our grammar schools
so many of our schools are actually full
um in terms of uh place planning
um it's fundamental obviously to our
role
as a strategic commissioner of school
places
and it's important we have a legal
sufficiency duty
to ensure that every child has access to
a school place and that legal duty is
met
so the department for education requires
us as a local authority to submit an
annual school capacity
survey we call it our scap and that
provides
forecasts then for both primary and
secondary places
and every local authority because um
different
local authorities apply different
methods really to forecast those people
places
and take all sorts of different factors
into account the local authority is
required
to submit a forecast methodology so that
that then demonstrates
its approach is robust and it's well
evidenced
and what i've done is in the report or
what has been done by the team
in the report is to share that forecast
methodology
we have six primary and five
secondary school planning areas and
those primary planning areas sit within
ultring and partington
sale e cell west stratford and ernst and
then our secondary planning areas are
ultragun partington sales stratford
and ernst and in terms of
how those projections are informed we
consider data from a number of sources
so we have the gp data and that's really
helps in terms of ensuring we have data
on those preschool children
and that comes into us at postcode level
we have school census data which
obviously gives us the number of
children on role
at each of our traffic schools we then
have the housing development data and
that's provided by the strategic
planning department and again that's
assigned to the
catchment areas and planning areas we
have our own
coordinated admissions data because that
enables us to forecast any movement of
children in and out of the local
authority
and then our historic cohort data is
really helpful in predicting
uh trends and patterns of movement that
may have occurred
over the last few years
and in terms of um housing developments
um again um pupil yield rates
um are are important really
in determining what the impact of
housing developments is going to be
upon our schools pupil yield rate
averages when homes are built three
pupils per school year
per 100 homes the primary and secondary
sector
in the sixth form sector that equates to
two pupils
per year group per 100 homes
and trafford strategic planning
department will give us a list
of those new housing developments that
have achieved planning permission
and this is divided it's divided into
two sections which is under
under development and committed as well
and as i say the data gives us the
catchment areas so we know
exactly which schools will likely be
affected by any of those nearby
developments
and this information as well is included
in the school capacity survey that we
send back to the dfe
because that funding then gets deducted
from our funding allocation
rather than added and that's because
um the expectation is that these places
are funded by the developer themselves
and obviously then if developer
contributions are not collected
the local authority then will have to
fund those places
from other sources
and in terms of how those developer
contributions are calculated
and they're actually based on a national
average cost which has been published by
the
department for education and that's to
ensure that the contributions reflect
the actual cost of providing the school
places
and those rates are suggested in the
report our primary
15 737 pounds per pupil and secondary
is just under 22 000 pounds per pupil
now our strategic priority in trafford
is always where we can to expand our
existing schools because it's important
we safeguard their financial viability
what we try to do is remove any mix
stage classes where you might have a mix
year 3 4 or a mixed year one and two
class
and so that we move to a full form of
entry
and so a either a a one
form of entry which would be 30 pupils
or a two form entry of
60 pupils um and this also enables us to
maximize the impact of the basic need
funding which we have whilst obviously
protecting our existing stock
and actually the local authority
trafford has been defined by
the dfe as an exemplar local authority
with regards to
its effective and efficient use of basic
need funding
analysis has been undertaken of all of
our current schools our existing schools
now in terms of
potential for expansion so feasibility
studies have been carried out
and while some schools have now been
fully expanded there are
a number of schools where there is still
potential to expand where required
it's also advised though that we do
maintain a cert an operational surplus
of five to ten percent that we we keep
hold of that because obviously there's
always going to be fluctuations in
demand
and parental choice so we do do need to
maintain some of that
and it's just worth noting that traffic
has received 464
000 pounds in terms of developer
contributions
in terms of our basic need funding we've
identified there
the amount of basic need funding that we
have
um over um the the last
uh certainly in terms of the 21 sorry 22
basic need funding
that's allocated at a rate of at primary
level
13 659 pounds per pupil and secondary
17757 per pupil
and over the last 10 years we've
received 78 million pounds of funding
and that's helped provide just under 3
700 additional places and we've outlined
in the report how that money has
actually been spent
in terms of opening a new school there's
a very clear procedure for opening a new
school
and that is through a free school
presumption route
that's the way new schools are
established
and they're always classified as free
schools now that means that obviously
they're new
academy provisions which means they're
independent of local authority control
and receive their funding directly from
the government
now um the local authority is
responsible for providing the site for
the new school
the delivering the capital programme and
that will be subsidised as well by the
local authority until it has sufficient
pupils to make it viable
it's important to note as well that any
school with less than two forms of entry
so a pupil admission number of 60
would not be considered to be
financially viable so new schools
generally have to be a two-form entry
and the decision for a free school
proposal will always lie with the
secretary of state
and finally just briefly in terms of our
send capital and our early years sector
as the report states over the last um
three years
our capital allocation first for special
educational needs
has been just under million eight
hundred thousand pounds
and we've completed a range of schemes
at uh
many of our special schools including
edgerton and manor
uh picture i think uh the delamere
hydrotherapy pool clara's we had
photographs of it this week it looks
fantastic that's finally been finished
as well
and we actually have secured um the
go ahead if you like to progress the
expansion of the small specialist class
at lostock high
because again that's where we deemed we
needed some additional places
and actually parents are requesting
those places so that's been really
positive
and in terms of the early years sector
again it's
it's quite a buoyant child care market
that we have in trafford we have one of
the highest number of child care places
in england
for the population of nought to fives
and
there's a mixture there of child minders
and settings
and we also have three of our primary
special schools that have early years
units too
and and what should also be recognized
is trafford is a net importer of those
early year
years places so there are more out of
two outer borough children that come
into trafford to access
a preschool or an early years provision
then there are traffic children going
out
to different areas and what we are
obviously continuing to monitor is the
impact of covid on the early years
sector
and some of the the nurseries and and
pvis will
have been impacted uh by the by covid by
parents not wanting to secure
places anymore at the moment we don't
see
a sufficiency issue but we are
continuing to monitor it as the pandemic
rolls forward
thank you any questions now
thank you karen that was really um
helpful and thank you for
the reports and all the officers that
have been involved in it
could i ask people um if there are any
questions to either put it in the chat
um or to use the raised hand function
yeah thank you chad um can you hear me
okay
i'm sorry i'm i'm not hearing anybody
can you hear me okay
yes yes we can cancel one thank you
um uh thank you very much karen for the
report
um it was a really good insight to your
methodology
and some of the issues that you face
and deal with um and thank you to all
the the officers who put that together
um i have a few questions if i may share
um that center around table
uh sorry section 3.4
and then little a little later 6.3
so maybe karen and the officers that are
here you might want
to have a look at those points and i
have two or three questions around that
chair with your permission
um which are kind of interlinked um
my first question is karen am i am i
right in
section 3.4 to presume
that that table does not include free
school
places that have been provided over that
10-year period
do you want to come in on this um
sorry go on over to you claire um these
are the schools that we've expanded
using trafford's basic need
capital allocation um and there are no
free schools in that
so um if you're referring to um say
altering boys for example they're not
included in that list of places
do you have that information to hand
because i think when we're talking about
um school places and what's available
and what's being provided
that would be useful i appreciate you
may not have it
immediately to hand i've not got
immediately to hand but it will
be available if um but those places are
being funded separately
and directly by the dfa rather than
through our funds which is why it's not
reflected but we can get that
information if you require it
yeah thank you very much that would be
helpful um in particular do you have any
idea
what proportion of new school places
are free school
um
[Music]
so you broke up a little bit
emojis i'm just trying to get a handle
of
do you know roughly what proportion of
our new school places of three school
places and which are local authority
it so in terms of the free school places
claire
um i suppose are we talking about the
expansion of the grammar school
funds that were made available to our
grammar schools
and that would be where i would look at
the yeah yeah
that's right and there was some that was
quite ring fenced as well as
um i'm not sure whether you're aware of
that council london's
because that was around trying to
increase the number of vulnerable
children or children with free school
meals
um accessing uh grammar schools
so there was some uh kind of ring
fencing and that was part of obviously
the the bids that the
the schools put forward um but we can
probably we can go away and
find out exactly what what proportion of
places have been offered through those
expansions
i think we've had um altering and boys
ultraman girls and stratford grammar
have all been successful in those bids
yeah i think it'd be really interesting
to have a look at what proportion of
new school places in the borough over
the last three years
have been provided for free school
places
and those under the local authority
control
and where you know where those have gone
i think also as you say
some of the ring fence places in the
free schools
were dependent on increasing the number
of vulnerable
or poorer students i would i would
really like to have a look
at how that's going if you could
possibly provide a report
and with the chair's permission that may
be something that the scrutiny committee
would like to look at in future i'd
certainly like to recommend that
we we can certainly sorry
we can certainly look into that uh
council along and i think
certainly part of the um the remit of
the bid was
you know that they were able to evidence
that those places did go
did actually meet the needs of our
vulnerable children um
and they were asked to forecast the
percentage of growth
of the vulnerable children actually
accessing those those provisions
and they also had to evidence how they
were going to link in with some of our
traffic primary schools to secure again
the connections
and make sure that that you know those
pupils knew that they were eligible to
to apply so um claire that's something
we can certainly
uh perhaps discuss at school places and
see if we can get hold of that
information
thank you chair may i have your
permission to ask a follow-up
question yes certainly it was one on
item six
was it yes it was chair um thank you
thank you very much chad um yeah if we
look at section 6.3
in the report and consider the 520
estimated additional secondary school
places
needed for trafford in 2021-22
do you have any idea of how many of that
estimate is for trafford
and non-traffic children
claire do you have any information on
that one
i'm just looking at the section sorry um
it's the scorecard yeah the scorecard
yeah the
um the second skills yeah for secondary
um i haven't got a breakdown of what
whether they'd be
trafficked or non-trafficked do you mean
um
coming out well coming over the border
as an
as an import yeah i guess i'm i'm making
some assumptions here because uh you
know there's a lot of background
information to that scorecard am i right
in assuming
that those estimated additional places
would include estimates based on
children that travel
into the borough as in in addition to
our actual traffic residents
yeah the scorecard data um is
based on our school capacity um
calculation that we submit to annually
to the dfe um and within that
calculation because we are a net
importer it will assume
um and rather than it just being
trafford residents that there is an
expectation that additional
um because we are a net importer that we
will need to provide those places moving
forward as well
yeah i think i think obviously it's
interesting as a traffic counselor to
see
uh the extent to which school places in
the borough either provided through the
free school meal
means or indeed through the council are
going to school
children that reside outside of the
borough i would have thought that would
be interested to all councillors
um that would be really we do hold that
actually council london so i know
um admissions i don't you remember
claire it's a while ago i think even the
secondary colleagues were asking for
that information so
we do have some percentages of in terms
of our secondary schools how many
non-traffic children attend the schools
and how many traffic children attend our
secondary sector so
if if that will be helpful we can pull
that data down thank you so much
and forgive me for going on i just have
one final uh question now
and that's linked to
again in this figure of 520 estimated
additional secondary school places which
if you look at the total in that bar it
says
obviously it's a significant proportion
i'm just wondering um typically
is is the proportion
from the estimated figure for 21.22
over the last say the last three
academic years to what extent
have we been up actually able to meet
this demand
and as you can see from the table we
started to meet that demand by
um the additional works that we're
providing at blessed thomas holford
that's currently on site and that goes
some way to
um to capture that um
demand within that area and it's it's
under ongoing review as to how we can
um continue to maintain that provision
in the secondary sector as well and it's
as you can imagine slightly more
complicated
with all the different governance around
and secondaries as well
yeah i think that goes back to my
earlier comment about table 3.4 about it
not including the free school
places so i just want to get a picture
of
you know are we meeting that demand
because that's an estimated
uh an estimator of demand
if you like or school place is actually
needed as you said some coming from
non-trafford students some coming from
trafford
and but then it doesn't really answer it
doesn't give me really give me an idea
an idea of the extent to which we're
actually meeting
uh those uh that demand or those number
of places and the reason i asked it is
one of our colleagues
i think it was uh councillor uh kerry
forgive me council if i'm wrong i think
you raised
the issue and around um whether trafford
is actually
um providing the school places in terms
of the demand that's out there
so it's kind of linked to that question
that he raised at council last week
i hope that's i hope i'm not speaking
out of place there councillor kerry
maybe you're alluding to something else
i think i think certainly um uh
council london at the moment in terms of
secondary school places
uh and claire you might be able to
support in that um
we we do have capacity currently
within the secondary sector to meet the
demand
uh you know we are managing that as
claire said obviously we're looking
we we've um we're expanding bth
and but actually the expansion for bth
is more of a
site expansion isn't it um i think
claire to to meet
uh the current number of children they
have on site anyway
um so um in terms of the actual
pupil admissions number there's not an
awful lot of uplift there
um but um and obviously there are still
surplus places in some of our other
secondary
secondary schools i think that you know
as claire has alluded to it
sometimes is the complexities of the
grammar school system because obviously
they will inevitably
take some children in from out of
borough rather than always
you know necessarily being completely
our traffic population
thank you thank you very much karen i
really look forward to receiving some of
that information
um particularly around the free school
and the breakdown for the individual
skills and
the issue you raised about the uh the
new free school
places for the grammar schools and
whether they're meeting
the the funding criteria yeah thank you
thank you so much thank you very much um
did you have a question counselor carey
yes please thank you i'll just put my
hand down otherwise i'll be there all
night
thanks very much and thank you for the
report and i asked for this report to
come here because
i sit on planning committee and for
example in partington just
last week we put through 600 homes
and 150 of them we got some money for
for
schooling we didn't get anything for the
other half of
the other bigger amount of of houses
being built and i'm
and i'm seeing this more more often now
and um you know
we just greater manchester had the
spatial framework i know that that's all
of it
funny now and i'm not sure what's going
on there we're either going to make a
plan ourselves
or there's going to be another spatial
framework with nine boroughs that's
going to be the development of
thousands of new homes in the borough i
just can't see a plan anywhere
i can't see one when i look at these
documents and thank you for these
documents by the way
i see on uh table 47 here
estimated number of additional places to
meet abandoned primary school of 330
that's the size of a primary school a
small primary school you know are we
i can't see any any plans for any
developments of any primary schools
anywhere
520 for secondary school i work at the
biggest school in trafford
our population is 500 i think
we have massive demand to get in in sale
and
you know every three years is that a
massive prime secondary school that
needs to be built
i've lived in this borough since i was
born and you know the education traffic
has always been one of the best in the
country
we're all that proud of it you know you
guys won't make that what make that
happen and the teachers and
the parents of trafford when i grew up
and went to
i went to a sixth form college in
manchester all the people all my friends
who lived in children did spree they all
wanted to move here to trafford and now
they all are having their babies here
because
they're sending their kids to our
schools it's a magnificent success for
it story
like council london said at the
beginning of his um
speeches he understands the pressures i
understand the pressures but these are
long
term pressures that have always been on
this borough and i just can't see a plan
i can see 3.4 as council london was
saying
you know the last time there's no
primary school development going on
at all now at the minute the last one
was worthington in
2020 and i can't see any development for
primary school provision at the minute
you know in 4.1 uh the majority of
trafford primary schools are at capacity
so any developer must be expected to
fund the cost of new pupils generated
like i just suggested we just excuse me
we just voted through in planning last
week i brought it up
numerous counselors brought it up there
is no plan for those those pupils at the
minute
already the residents there are already
struggling to get their their children
in
the majority of secondary schools are
full
although most have a capacity to
accommodate pupils
my school's an example we do not have
the capacity to accommodate more pupils
since 2012 trafford has received a total
of 464 000 developer contributions
that figure according to your the
figures in this document about
the cost of building a new school the
cost of even building a
you know a side room on a school that
figure is tiny
since 2012 and
i just i just can't see a plan i just
love there to be a plan
there probably is one somewhere i don't
know i just can't see any evidence here
of what we're doing to ensure the people
who live here now
not these developments that are
happening are coming to this area or the
children who the young people who live
here want to stay in this area
have a secure amazing primary school and
secondary school like you said 94
of them are good or outstanding we may
be
hitting our legal duty like you've said
i imagine it's a battle
every year to hit that legal duty to get
some of these children
into some of our secondary schools and
primary schools and i bet it cost us
quite a fortune to move them around all
over the borough
i was just expecting tonight that what
you've given us the methodology
all the information the demand which
you've given us which is very frank and
fantastic
but then i was expecting to see after it
the plan
the plan just as it stands right now for
the developments that are happening now
what is the plan for sale for primary
schools for example what is the actual
plan
not this ad hoc oh my god the first
needs another teacher
what is the plan what is the long term
plan for the development of this borough
and it's
magnificent education that we provide
for our residents
and hopefully you've got a question out
of that somewhere sorry if i rub with a
little bit
no thank you the report is brilliant
honestly i just can't see it on anywhere
yeah thank you no problem counselor
karen i think
i think certainly but what you've really
um i think articulated really well is
how challenging it actually is
uh and it is you know it is a really
really kind of complex
um picture really and piece of work
claire do you want to talk about the
kind of
the development and the pupil yield and
some of the contacts behind the furs
would that be helpful
um i can do yes i mean what um what we
do as
you all know sitting on planning
committee and we will um liaise with our
colleagues in planning
and we're asked to comment on each of
the
um development proposals coming forward
um
we use the yield um as in the report of
three primary pupils or secondary pupils
per
per year group and per 100 homes as
as rationale for asking for these
contributions and as councilor kerry
said the amount of money we've received
in
from developer contributions um since
2012
is minimal and there was a slight change
in the way we were able to ask
for that and i think with um and it's
been reintroduced now that we can ask
for section 106 monies again and that's
what we
that's what we're doing and we're moving
forward with that and we're liaising
with our
our colleagues in planning over each of
those developments that are coming
forward
um and karen was um just referring to
the first primary school so the basic
need
and report was approved by executive
um and is was out of calling uh
yesterday
and so we're moving forward with the
proposal there
um and looking um at moving that from
two forms to three forms of entry
and so from a point of view of a plan
for sale that's
um that's where we're focusing and the
funding
um at this point in time and that again
and looking at and the housing and in
the short term and
you know the longer term and that
carrington development is obviously
backing onto the back of sale west there
and um will be
will grow in time over phases and that's
where
that's where we're focusing our energy
at the moment in the funding for sale
thank you council hines did you want to
say a few words yeah thanks so i
think what this report probably does is
it it
articulates really um the criteria
that that is laid down um in terms of
of how and when we're able to expand
either expand existing school place
provision
um which is very very clear um and so we
are only able to do it within those
confines
and it also very clearly articulates um
when we are able to build new schools
and the circumstances under which we're
able to do that
and and so when there are large-scale
developments it's as they come
in that we are then able to look at how
big is that development going to be are
we then
in a position that we will be needing to
have a new school
and it is obviously going to be a very
fine line because you can see that some
of the
um some of the developments are not
going to warrant
a a full kind of new school
and so we wouldn't be in a position to
to do that or even advocate for it
um in in other developments some of them
are are smaller and so again you're only
able to do it at the point at which you
know that development has come in
i think the two things are quite
different though in terms of what you
you sort of talking about their
counselor kelly because i think what
we've got is
is the actual plan for what we are going
to
do based on the developments that we
know
are going to happen that doesn't mean
that there isn't
also um a discussion that is ongoing
about
well what will we need to do if there
are
and as we know there are further
developments coming down the line and
the place shaping board
very much deals with that um
now that's not what this report is is
aimed or designed to do it
it's telling us what are our sufficiency
needs based on the information that we
know for sure
and how are we going to tackle that so
the two things are very different i
don't think it's fair to say that there
isn't a plan because i think the plan is
very clear
clearly laid out in that report um
and then beyond that in terms of you
know what will we need to do in the
future
of course there are ongoing horizon
scanning
um discussions that take place at play
shaping board thanks
thank you um councillor hines and many
thanks to
karen and claire um fought for that
report
um oh apologies councillor holden
you have a question
now please don't apologize i can't get
into the chat
otherwise i would have done that um
several of the points that i took out of
the report
have been partially covered already but
i just like to
ask a couple of questions or make a
couple of points
the data sources that are listed for
school places and calculations
i appreciate that the only ones that
we've got to handle on
but i couldn't see any way that we make
an adjustment or a judge
on the migration at various ages through
the school process
of people buying houses in
the borough and bringing their families
and their children with them
specifically for um for the school
had no warning of that as far as i can
see and
is that a problem are we do we have
plans for it
the other question i had has partly been
covered just
about developer contributions what's our
level of success
in actually collecting the contributions
that are due
for each of these developments and to
follow on the
professor carey's point with this
newfound desire
to build something on everything
that hasn't actually got foundations on
it at the moment
um we're going to have whole new
communities
and i'm beginning to see
primary school pupils being asked to
travel
considerable distances to
their schools rather than being educated
locally
now primary school children cannot
travel by bus
and over about a mile and a half they
can't walk
so we're running the risk of expanding
the schools that we have now
in residential areas with traffic
problems and making it worse
so i think if i can have a feel for
whether or not we're thinking about
those at least
i don't have any answers perhaps uh some
of you do
thank you
claire do you want do you want to talk
about in terms of the data
sources that we use in order to
certainly planned for some of the places
and and
you know in terms of the kind of
carrying i suppose
some of the information around um again
that's that fluidity really of people
moving into the area
um i can do karen yeah i mean this
obviously isn't um
is it my area and this is where having a
marilyn monroe
has been very useful um so apologies um
i mean as you can see we've got the data
sets in there there is there is an
element of
um what's being called a survival rate
um within these
um in the narrative of the um of the
report
which is taking into account that
actually say for example
in the altering area and going from year
six to year seven
there's a very high uplift and we're a
net importer within the altringham area
because of our
very popular grammar schools and very
high achieving
um schools in the area so
that uplift is accounted for within the
forecasting
um obviously at that point if they do
bring younger siblings with them
um then at that point they will
will fit in with and presumably the
inuit um
transition that is is normally the usual
process for in an
admission round that's in year um again
i'm not the admissions manager so i'm
unfortunately i can't give you too much
more detail on that but
i'm aware that the the uplift
of coming into the secondary sector is
accounted for within the forecasting
no i don't have i'm just trying to get
my hand down
um yeah thank you chad just a quick one
um i think and the point that counselor
carrier aide
uh raises about you know it's great to
see the report the data that's provided
it gives us a picture of how things are
calculated
of course with any report it raises as
many questions as it answers and i think
the the request by councillor kerry
uh for some kind of outline of what the
plan is
uh even if that's getting an insight
from the
um the board that councillor hind heinz
mentioned earlier on
if information from that from those
discussions so we can get a sense of
you know even in the short term whilst
we have that projected figure
of 520 places being estimated to be
needed in the secondary
schools for 2122. i've
i've been given no idea to this evening
by the count
by the officers whether we have any idea
if we're going to be able to meet that
for that academic year and that for me
you know
right here right now would be really
really useful so we could
we could come back in a future meeting
with that information with an idea of
you know
how we're going to be meeting um those
places in the future is it gonna be
further expansions of schools
the extent to which free school places
you know fall into that mix
or we're talking about new builds i'd
i'd really welcome that
um if there are no no more questions
um can i thank claire and karen um
claire you're more than welcome to stay
but if you need to go somewhere
um oh sorry counselor holden
thanks chair um i did ask a question
about the
rate of success that we have
for collecting monies i didn't seem to
pick up an answer to that
um apologies councillor holden um
the change to the how we collect the
section 106 monies um is relatively
recent so we've been
um that money had been pulled under the
um construction infrastructure lavig and
the still
um and that's how the funding had been
coming into trafford
and now we're moving forward and we're
able to ask for direct contributions
and from developers for education that's
something that's um
i say relatively recent in the last 12
months so obviously
um each of those agreements will be
dependent on um individual legal
contracts with those contractors
as to when those um amounts will come
into the council
and i'm aware that the council has um a
section 106 officer that obviously
monitors that and make sure that those
collections
are coming in and so we are requesting
them and at the moment we're not seeing
an influx of that just at the moment
because
they've not quite got to the point of um
building those properties in order to
to trigger releasing that um money over
to us but um
there's a there's a councillor officer
that um looks after that
thank you if there are no more questions
can we move on to item five
and which is an update on the position
of schools and how children are
progressing in education
through the pandemic and i believe we
have um
lindsay burridge and karen samples on
that one
thank you thanks councillor weston um
if we can we'd like to share a
powerpoint if that's okay just to kind
of guide people because
we are a bit of a double act and you've
probably had two papers that have been
sent to you
one which is mine which is kind of a
generic overview
of the position of schools and then
lindsay
as head of virtual school has done a
paper that is very specific obviously to
our looked after children so hopefully
you can see that thanks lindsay
um and lindsay's gonna be my um great
assistant
and move on through the slides if if
that's all right with you lindsay that'd
be
that'd be fantastic so and i was asked
to obviously we were asked to provide an
update on the position of schools and
how children are progressing
um through the pandemic so um if we can
go on to
the next slide please lindsay thank you
um obviously you know i think as i've
said in the report it's been um
it's been a challenging time for schools
um
since almost a year ago now um
and you know particularly we've i think
um
schools and their leaders have had to
continue to respond and react
and as the best they can uh due to the
obviously the changes that the pandemic
has
has uh created some of the challenges uh
and updates in in
a guidance from the department for
education
and what i have reported in the
report is around the covered cases and
in terms of since the start of lockdown
really last year
schools have been supported by a variety
of officers
really from across public health health
and safety and education just to make
sure that they're able to provide a
covered safe environment
for our children and to maintain high
levels of attendance
as best they can and those officers have
been able to
give um weekly briefings in terms of
numbers from across the different parts
of the borough
and they've held question and answer
sessions every
two weeks for schools and that's been
really helpful to provide support for
significant issues
to walk them through different scenarios
that our schools are facing
uh throughout this pandemic um and also
to support with risk assessment
completion as well
um we've also provided various
information including frequently asked
questions that have been shared with
schools and that includes personnel
issues
as well as actual environmental sort of
issues in keeping schools safe
where we have um had a significant
number of cases in schools
and thankfully that is beginning to
stabilize
i think um certainly since since the
start of this year
we have always stepped up our outbreak
control meetings with schools and their
leaders
um again just to ensure that they are
supported
um but also that we're assured that
there's nothing
uh that needs to be considered um within
the provision
and those have been attended by public
health colleagues again health and
safety colleagues as well as the school
representatives
and at that point we've always discussed
the quality of remote learning that's
been provided for those children who
have had to be sent home because of
covid
more recently we've had a working group
that's been stepped up as well to
support the rollout of testing
in schools and that's made up of
school leaders from across secondary
special schools and primary schools
again as well as colleagues from across
public health uh
health and safety and legal and the
actual
rollout of testing has been quite well
received actually
um across the sector obviously the
secondary schools i think because
they've had lower numbers of children in
they've been able to roll it out quite
successfully although they did have to
spend some time just making sure they
got the right staffing in the right
environment set up
and the risk assessment in place as well
most critically
and again what's been really positive
very recently is that
all of our special school staff who are
deemed to meet the personal care needs
of their children
are also able to access a vaccination
and i think again that's been really
helpful in building
confidence in the system as well whilst
we manage some of these complexities
so in the report i did give the
breakdown of some of the numbers
in terms of pupil cases staff cases and
obviously those affected them
and having to isolate and i would just
like to say that some of those numbers
do reflect the early years sector
um because obviously we did we did see
quite an increase in in cases in the
early years sector following christmas
um which probably was a result of them
being open for a longer period of time
over the christmas time so thanks
lindsey if we can go on to
the next um slide and i've reported a
little bit around attendance again
within the report
um obviously from september attendance
was mandatory so it's it was business as
usual
schools open everyone back in um and
schools can complete an online
attendance portal which is provided by
the department for education but this is
optional and so not all of our schools
do complete that portal
and what it is helpful as a local
authority is for us to be able to really
look at
the proportion of children who are
vulnerable who are attending
um as well as uh consider the impact of
covid cases upon attendance in schools
as well
um so we use that as a monitoring tool
as well and that's helpful for us to
just get those assurances that our
attendance is strong
obviously from january when we went into
lockdown again we saw the restrictions
then placed
uh and that was just restricted to
children of critical workers and the
vulnerable children but they've widened
the kind of definition of vulnerable
children now
to not just take children with an
educational health and care plan and
those known to social care
but also any other reason for them being
vulnerable which is a kind of local
discretion
and discretion of schools but also those
that couldn't access a
device to access digital online learning
um it has been quite a challenge i would
say for schools to meet the demand
for places particularly for uh critical
workers and some of that is obviously
because the list the definition of
critical workers has been changed it's
been expanded now
but schools have also had to really try
and
understand what they can physically do
within the capacity that they have from
a a
provisional site capacity but also the
numbers of staff that they have on site
whilst trying to deliver both remote
learning
as well as face-to-face learning for
those children in school
so there's lots of complexities that our
schools have had to
have to work around what i did do was
try and
do a reach out for schools to try and
understand the level of request for
places that came in from parents
and those that were actually allocated
and when you look at that
we are looking at a 96 attendance rate
so 96 of places that were requested
were being met within some of the the
constraints that the schools were
working in
and certainly our attendance rates for
children with a social worker and those
with an educational
health and care plan are actually um
very strong in comparison with
our neighboring authorities across
greater manchester
um the most recent data we've actually
seen is those children within
educational health and care planner
are the highest in in gm which is a
really positive place to be
so um we are aware of some children who
um have really struggled to access
education for a long period of time
because of
a real level of covert anxiety in the
families
and certainly we've linked him with
those particular schools to look at how
we can positively support parents
to build that confidence back into the
system to reassure them that school is a
safe place
but just to make sure that you know we
we are really supporting those families
and those children are accessing the
level of learning
thanks lindsay um on to the next slide a
little bit around electively home
educated
i think we've reported before that you
know we've nationally there's been an
increase in
um families who are um electing to home
educate their children
um the report i think said 178 we're now
at 182 so that's gone up slightly
although i would say that the numbers
are stabilizing quite significantly now
we saw a bit of a peak
uh in the first couple of months but it
is beginning to stabilize
and when we look at the the kind of
proportional increase
from say christmas 20 2019
um then actually our increase is just
over
about 30 and when we compare that with
some of our neighboring authorities
some of them have seen over 100 increase
so ours are actually
it's it's okay we we have a dashboard
where we
uh sort of look at the um profile if you
like of the children
who are being electively home educated
and some of the reasons that families
are citing
and the majority um of our children
are it's interesting actually they're
coming from the north of the borough
stratford is a
is a is a place where we do see a higher
number
um and a higher number of children are
of primary age
when we send the forms out and families
fill in the forms
we ask them to indicate their reasons
and the most
popular reasons if you like for home
educating
is for their own philosophical their own
reasons some of them have
have kind of enjoyed spending the extra
time with their families during
lockdown they believe that they can they
see it's a positive experience of
children being at home and enjoying a
different
aspect of the curriculum some are
dissatisfied with the system
they might find that the work isn't
meeting the needs of the children the
class sizes are too big or that maybe
again some of the children are are
have been happier during lockdown but
what we have seen is a higher rate of
people actually citing covid
as a reason for electively home
educating as well as well as medical
so we do work with our schools and our
families to support them
uh those those children who who are at
home
thanks lindsay in terms of remote
learning
um you've probably been aware that since
october schools have had that legal duty
to provide a remote education for
our school-aged children who aren't able
to attend school
and the department has published um lots
of guidance on what remote education
should
should look like um and obviously i've
listed uh in the report
um some of the aspects of what the
expectation is and
and that is around still being ambitious
still setting meaningful activities in
various subjects
um the dfe is obviously provided
a specific length of time that should be
allocated to to learning through the day
and that's shared in the report i think
it's important as well that
remote education isn't just digital uh
it doesn't have to be
just digital that it could be activities
it could be and work that's sent home
there could be work packs that could be
workbooks
i think one of the most important things
that we're sharing with schools at the
moment is that it isn't just about the
provision but it's also about levels of
engagement so you can have a
a wonderful offer for remote learning
but if children aren't engaging in
accessing it then it's pointless and
meaning
meaningless so it's important that
schools have those systems in place to
ensure that they're engaging
and that also touches on safeguarding as
well that
you know the schools have got eyes on
these children and we know exactly
what's happening to them if they're not
in school
we do have a protocol as well that that
we do and
share with colleagues in children's
social care so
if there are any concerns raised by
schools that um
children aren't engaging they're at home
we do have
it they are known to social care and we
just need to make sure that they
are okay and that they're safe and
they've got a device
if required then we do link him with
with our social care officers to support
that
i will just say one of the things that
has obviously arisen is
the digital divide really does still
exist for our children in trafford
the dfa have obviously allocated some
further devices
and are looking at trying to increase us
access
and looking at broadband provision etc
but
certainly when we did a reach out to
schools we were made aware that
we still had there was a request for 844
devices
that's laptops that was a request from
from our schools
101 tablets what we tend to find is that
younger children like to have access to
tablets
and 110 wi-fi dongles so it was
it was really clear that there was an
issue in terms of
of children actually being able to
access learning
more recently what we have done is we've
had an allocation of 150 laptops from
aqa which is a local company
and so what we've done is we've
prioritized the requests from schools
according to their vulnerabilities so
looking at children who are either known
to social care
or where there's a number of children in
the family but they've only got one
device
well there's been some level of crisis
in the family and then
equally targeted some of our key year
groups like
um year 10 and 11 and like year five and
six
where you know clearly um they're really
some of these children really do need to
be able to make sure they've got
learning in place
but there is we have made it clear with
schools as well that those children
um should be able to access the school
place as well where required
thank you lindsay and on onto a little
bit about catch up loss learning again
you'll be aware of the the funding
that's been made available to schools
um schools have been reporting how
they're using their catch-up premium and
a lot of that is available on their
websites and
and certainly that's done through small
group one-to-one support intervention
programmes etc
and the remote learning offer we have
provided all sorts of toolkits of
support and again schools are required
to share that with their governors
so if you're governors hopefully you
will have seen the remote learning offer
that your schools have provided
and they're also available on the
website too so parents will be able to
see what the expectations are
thank you lindsay
in terms of our pupils with special
educational needs and
again the the department for education
have provided some updated guidance for
those children with special education
reasonable specialist settings
and the the department made it clear
that special schools should continue to
welcome and encourage their
the children to attend full-time where
parents wish for that to happen
um what the department has also said is
that you know on occasions they
recognize that special schools may
um encounter those difficult situations
or circumstances
where they can't provide the usual level
of intervention and provision
and because of staffing ratios or the
specialisms that's required
and so the department has said that
where in these circumstances where
where they can to resume as close as
possible to the
the children's uh specified provision um
but they recognize that that sometimes
that isn't always um
we're not always able to do that just
because of the circumstances that the
specialist schools are in
i think the other thing as well that
we've made clear with our schools is
that
um within the educational health and
care plan where it isn't possible for
schools and services to
deliver um as they would like then there
has to be a real kind of opening on this
conversation with families so that
collectively they can co-produce and
work in partnership
to consider what is the art of the
possible and what alternatives can be
put in place
thank you lindsay um
just a little bit about what's been
happening within our schools
our sensory impairment service are
continuing to support children who are
in school
face to face um certainly the
educational psychology service has been
working really really closely with
trafford parent carer forum
um throughout the lockdown really to
consider
you know any reasonable adjustments the
risk assessments that some of our
specialist provisions have got in place
for our children
the daily check-ins i think with the
trafford parent care reform has been
invaluable so that we can deal with any
issues
quickly and source solutions and also
some of the parent consultations and
webinars and
question and answer sessions have been
really well received by
parents uh specialist provisions have
also received support from
from some of our um health services as
well but we do also recognize that
you know some adjustments have had to be
made because of covered incapacity
issues
thank you lindsay finally and i
i realized um kicked myself really i
hadn't put this in the report but a
little bit about mental well-being
because this is really really critical
and this is not not necessarily cans
because that's really the kind of the
high-end critical part of the service
but um all local authorities also have
an allocation of funding for well-being
for education
so it's a government project and this is
around developing capacity within
schools and within the system
to enable schools to be effective
provisions to support the mental health
of our children
and so we've got to plan the educational
psychology services delivering a series
of webinars and training sessions for
our schools
around anxiety and attachment and it is
about really equipping staff to be able
to deliver it themselves
in their settings um we've also got all
sorts of support being wrapped around
including emotion
coaching training and some emotional
literacy literacy support assistant
training for our
teaching assistants and there's a
research project going on around
emotionally based school non-attendance
and we produced a mental wealth toolkit
to support as well which
helps schools and parents actually to be
signposted to
specific places of support thanks
lindsay
i think it's over to you now lindsay
thanks karen um so hi i'm i'm lindsay
i'm
the second part of the double act and
i'm virtual school head for looks after
children
um and i've been in post since 2013 but
this is my first
trip to scrutiny so you'll have to bear
with me and i'm really excited
to be here and talk to you about the
education of looked after children which
is absolutely a passion for me
and i know that you want to specifically
find out a bit more about how things
have been going
for our looked after children in
education during the pandemic
and so hopefully you've seen the report
which has got a bit more information but
i've just got some
headlines here to talk about and so this
was we we monitor the attendance of our
looked after children very closely
uh we have an online register so i can
check each day
who's in school which is really useful
and so this is
the pattern of attendance through the
autumn term day by day
and you can see the gray lines at the
bottom are children that were absent
the orange bit at the top actually those
children officially were present at
school although they were actually at
home because they were
marked with an x code which meant that
they were self-isolating due to covert
it does count in terms of attendance
statistics it counts as a present mark
and so our attendance during the autumn
term and sat between
um 90 and 95 and each day
which i think compares favorably to um
to other virtual schools in the
conversations i've been having and also
to attendance nationally
um it's still lower than our usual
attendance so our average attendance was
around 90
and in the autumn term which is a lot
which is lower than we normally have so
it is of concern
and it's also worth noting that 208 of
our
children that's about three quarters of
our looked after children
had an x code during the autumn term so
that they were
self-isolating and not in school during
the autumn terms and that's a really
high
proportion of our looked after children
and it was particularly concerning when
we looked at those children who'd had a
significant amount of time
off school self-isolating so more than
two weeks
which would be the amount of time that
you might expect a child to have been
off if they're bubble adverse
and those children there were 18
children who had been up for more than
two weeks
and around a third of those are placed
with their own parents and so that's a
it's a group of children that we're
particularly
concerned about and i'm i'm liaising
with pamela and other and social care
colleagues to think about the additional
support that we can put in
for those children um
the next slide is kind of bringing this
bang up today and actually i've put last
week on which wasn't in the report
because i wrote the report last week
and so you can see what attendance looks
like at the moment
and we're really pleased that um just
about 60
of our children are physically in school
and each day
and at the moment and that's
significantly higher than the first
lockdown in the first lockdown we had
about 20
of our children in at the beginning and
then by the summer holidays we had about
40
of our children so we're starting at a
much higher baseline
this time and also compares really
favorably
to national data so and around 41
of children with a social worker are
attending school nationally so we're
significantly higher than that
and the yellow bar at the top so that
orange bar is the children that are
physically going to school
the yellow bar there is c code so that's
children that are choosing to learn at
home
and we have around 70 to 80 and some
children are in part time so each day it
varies a little bit
we have between 70 and 80 children and
where the families are choosing for them
to learn at home
and so that's about 30 of our cohort
and and we're doing phone calls those
families we're encouraging them to go
into school and we're also
linking in really closely with social
care to make sure that there's no risk
attached to that child
that child not being in school and then
the other the grey bits are x codes so
that's children who are
um off not able to attend school due to
covert so perhaps they've had a positive
test
or somebody in their family has so
they're self isolating
and then that tiny little bit at the top
is children that are absent for other
reasons so that's children
as in any time and that might be off
school with chickenpox or
um or whatever and so they're not in
school for other reasons
so hopefully that gives you a bit of a
breakdown of what things look like
right up to the minute for our children
there's a lot of words on this slide i
apologize for that i just wanted to give
you kind of a
one slide that just showed you kind of
our approach as a virtual school to
um to the pandemic and
in september we um contacted all of the
117 school articles that i looked after
children attend
to get an idea of what their home
learning offer would be so that we could
be assured
that if our children were required to be
at home due to self-isolation
that they would have a really robust
home learning office we collated all of
that information
back in september since christmas
um we've contacted every family of every
looked after child
to encourage attendance at school and
if it has been deemed to be appropriate
that that child should be learning at
home so perhaps
uh with an elderly carer who's shielding
um
or the child has health needs and their
the decision has been made they're
better it's better to be at home
and then we're making regular phone
calls to make sure that their home
learning is going well
so we've rated all of those cases the
green cases are the children that are in
school because we hope that they're
getting a really great offer
um on the school site and amber cases
would be children where we
although they're home learning we're
confident that they're accessing the
learning and we're happy with what
they're getting
the red cases are those children where
we are more concerned about provision of
education they're getting weekly calls
and the person doing those calls is our
education
support worker who we appointed just
before christmas and who is really
focusing
on um maintaining contact with all of
those families who are doing home
learning
and making sure that they've got
everything they need and whether that's
over the phone or
doorstep and home visits if required
um our online register also provides
reports that get
um uploaded to the social care database
so any child
that's not in school either because
they're self-isolating
or because they've got chickenpox or
because they um
are choosing not to be in school and
home learning that information on a
daily basis is uploaded to the social
care database so that child social
worker
can see day by day whether they're in
school or not and they can use that to
inform their risk assessments
and throughout the pandemic we've
offered additional support to our
children and to begin with that was very
much focused on tuition but we've
expanded that offer
to mentoring and counselling because we
recognize that sometimes that's what our
children need
and they're available that additional
support is available to all of our
children
over the course of this last 10 11
months
we've had 156 children accessing this
additional support commission by us
and that's around 60 of the children of
our looked after children and we're also
offering access to it equipment and
things like craft resources books
magazine subscriptions
and we're promoting those when we're
making the phone calls to families and
via the child's personal education
planning meeting as well
and so far we've delivered over 200
laptops so considering we have
um i think 266 school age looked after
children this week
and we've provided our laptops to a
really high proportion of children
obviously some of our children had
laptops before any of this happened
and so we're really pleased that we've
been able to provide that equipment to
our children and then the final point
there is just about our school leavers
so last year's school leavers
and also now this year's school leavers
and they're a group of children that
we're particularly
concerned about and so we've kind of
adjusted
um workloads within the team to be able
to provide enhanced support to those
children so our careers advisor in the
team
has has moved her focus to looking at
our current
year 11's and also year 12s and year 13s
to make sure that they're engaging with
education because we're conscious that
you know with gcse's kind of swept off
the table last year
and it would have been very easy for our
children to become demotivated and
disengaged
and so we're really pleased that um 95
of our
school leaders last year went into
a positive post-16 and outcome so into
college or into a training provider
and we're really pleased that they've
maintained those placements over the
autumn term as well
and so there was a bit more detail i
think in the report and a case study in
there about that
um and then the final bit i just wanted
to talk about was personal education
plans
um personal education plans there are
statutory plans
and all looked after children have to
have completed each term
and and those plans have become even
more important than ever
in terms of making sure that
communication is there between schools
social worker
the family and the young person to make
sure that we're absolutely doing
everything that we possibly can
to make sure they're getting the best
education possible so the personal
education plan
is really our main assurance mechanism
when it comes to checking that our
children are getting
good quality education and are making
the progress that we want them to make
so we're really pleased that despite the
challenging circumstances
our personal education plan completion
remained high
and you probably noticed the dip in the
spring term i think that
was when schools were kind of reeling
with things we did struggle a little bit
to get schools to complete those
personal education plans
and in the spring term but since then
we've had over 90
completion for all of our children in
reception to year 11.
and we're really pleased to see an
increase in our post 16
pep completion as well so that's that
yellow line
and we've really struggled with post 16
pep completion in the past
and and i think our careers advisor now
kind of taking that
um group of children under her wing a
little bit has really helped to get that
post 16 pet completion
up and then the final slide
is about quality and so it's all very
well having a personal education plan
but actually it's no good if it's not um
clear about what you're trying to
achieve
clear about who's accountable for and
the actions
and and the young person should know as
well what is in the plan and what the
what and they should be doing to work
towards the outcomes
and so we quality assure perhaps um in
the autumn term the summer term each
year
and so that we can track um quality of
packs and make sure that they're really
smart plans with clear outcomes for
young people and we're really pleased to
see that our pecs
have really improved in terms of quality
in the autumn term just gone
so we have 58 of pets rated good or
outstanding
compared with 29 in the autumn term last
year
we know that there's still room for
improvement there we want more of our
pets to be
good or outstanding and that was
something that often raised when they
came in for
our children's service inspection and as
well so it is something that we're
working towards
we do have very high expectations for
those plans so
and i guess the difficulty is there's
not a standardized approach across local
authorities as to
what is a good pep and what is a
inadequate pep and what
you know there's not a standardized
approach and i do think in trafford we
do have very high standards
and we offer personalized one-to-one
training with designated teachers
and to help them understand and process
and to understand how to success
we also um provide feedback when we do
the quality assurance process as well so
that
people can learn and they get a one-page
um feedback form
telling them where they might want to
improve in future so um
we really hope that that improved
improved picture
will continue into the summer term as
well
um that's it from me i've got some nice
pictures because i like to show people
some of the the nice work that we get to
do in virtual school as well so there's
some nice pictures there of
some of our children ecosystem of our
opportunities as an excuse
and while i ask if you've got any
questions
thank you very much um to lindsay and to
karen
um a lot of information there does
anybody have any questions at all
could i make a comment please uh council
western yes certainly
thank you and fantastic it's magnificent
to hear everything you've been going
through and working towards
the reports brilliant you've been
through a hard time the schools are
doing magnificently
all these changing parameters all the
time i just wanna
he praise on you all uh you know
somebody works on the front line and see
some of these things that you guys have
been doing it's been brilliant
it's really nice uh to see uh
lindsay there uh i'm sure if i get that
wrong
i think we've met before actually at my
school it's magnificent
magnificent to see everything you've
been going on and i really like some of
the things that you said
in regards to uh the young people
knowing what or what are in their
reports and that was something that was
brought
offset about the children being more
involved in things it's great to hear
that
and it's great to see those improvements
you can see them on that graph it's
quite clear in the fact you've
you're still doing that my little tiny
point uh because i think it's all
brilliant
was you've got this new officer post um
i forgot that the title of the officer
post
and it was somebody who makes these
welfare calls i think to all the pupils
but we're only having one person
throughout this cove
whole crisis that we've been going
through is only sort of contingency in
the background there like if that person
was to self-isolate
or become ill throughout that period of
your experience that
and otherwise it's just fantastic all of
you are brilliant
thank you very much and well we feel
very lucky to have our education support
worker actually because
she only came to us just before
christmas and so for the rest of the
pandemic
we've really been sharing this workload
out between us as a team
so at the start of the pandemic in march
one of our first responses actually
was to divide all of our children into
caseloads so that each person in the
team whether they were
our careers advisor or our speech and
language therapists or
our educational psychologist or me we
all had a caseload of children and we
had around
50 children each um in terms of a
full-time
equivalent caseload some of our
part-time so we had fewer cases
and so we were kind of doing the work
ourselves at that point and making the
welfare calls ourselves
so actually we feel really lucky to have
tracy with us as our education support
worker doing that work now
and but other people in the team are
very aware of that work
and we i have friday afternoon meetings
with tracy each week where we literally
go through the register
because i'm a little bit of a control
freak and listen to what is happening
for each child all of our 266 children
and so i'm very aware of what's
happening so i think if tracy did have
to go off
and there would be a smooth transition
into a new person taking that piece of
work on
thank you um counselor dylan did you
have a question
sorry just people start speaking in the
house
when i'm typical really quickly because
i'm conscious of time can i just ask
karen
how many of the home educating children
have scnd
if you know that and another one that
you probably won't be able to
answer but i'm going to ask it anyway
just out of interest um
the catch-up funding if a lot of the
kids are working remotely at home
any idea how they're accessing that and
that's it for me thank you
thank you councillor dylan um we're
aware that seven children with sem
are electively home educated um what we
what we do do and we have a discussion
about this actually um earlier this week
because what we have set
stepped up now is a case review board
where we actually look at ehe children
we also look at children missing in
education
exclusions etc and it's just kind of
helping
me i think if anything to have a more
strategic oversight
um of some of our really vulnerable
children um
and and certainly i i was asking the ehe
officer how he links in with our send
officers as well
um just to make sure that um the right
support is provided for those families
um of scn children who who are at home
um so it is a small number of children
um
but nevertheless you know certainly when
it comes to
annual reviews when it comes to
determining whether the provision is
actually
sufficient because we obviously we do
have we do need to make sure that
that what's happening at home is right
for those children the scn
team the special educational needs team
are um
kind of own that that part of the the
business really so they they can make
the determination
that the quality of ehe is appropriate
for those children with educational
needs
um and obviously linking into the
required that the
actual detail within the educational
health and care plan
um with regard to the catch-up funding
so that was largely um sort of around
those that are actually at home and the
difference it's making i think that's a
really good question actually
um i can certainly do a little bit more
works i think what we'd have to do is
link in with the schools and have the
discussion with them
they obviously have the responsibility
for um you know
how that funding is used uh that the
accountability just sit with those
school leaders
and there are obviously tool kits where
good practices
is kind of shared about the effective
use of catch-up funding
and but that's something that we can
certainly try and get some insight from
the individual schools themselves
happy to do that thank you council dylan
thank you if there are no more questions
um i'd just
like to reiterate councillor carey's oh
apologies i've got some hands up now i
keep looking in chat for hands but um
so can i take um counselor procter
then councillor holden then councillor
acton please
thank you very much um i've got three
and
thanks for those presentations that was
packed full of useful information i'm
really glad to see
that um our special school staff
i have now got access to the vaccine
because
i've been getting um that raised
by certainly by delhi may school um
so that's great thank you um
so my questions are what's the cams
waiting list
time now because i've got um
children who have been waiting for a
very long time
and one in particular who's
witnessed experienced domestic violence
still hasn't got an appointment to see
somebody and i'm quite concerned
so would it be helpful counselor proctor
if i came in on that point
um because i i know i don't need to
tell you this but you you all know that
cams is a service that we commission
that we don't actually
are responsible for delivery of
but what we do have at the moment is
that we have a health subgroup that
reports
in terms of all of the contingency
actions the responding to
covid and the actions that
our health partners are taking we've
also stood back
up the children's commissioning group
and one of the areas that i know you'll
won't be surprised that we're taking an
active interest in
is in terms of cams and the search
planning
and they have enacted their search plan
they have
prioritized
doing initial consultations assessment
in terms of immediate risk and actually
understanding what
what children's needs are at that
initial point
so one of the things that we have asked
for is some detailed data
not just in terms of cams but our wealth
of emotional well-being
services the likes of couth because
you're absolutely
right to be asking the question we know
that
lockdown pandemic has had an adverse
impact on our
our children and our young people so we
have asked for that information to come
to the next
children's commissioning group which
will be in a few weeks time
and we're happy to bring some detailed
information back to
scrutiny if that would be helpful note
the comments
um in terms of health scrutiny that
people were saying what's happening
about cams
so more than happy to bring something
back if that would be helpful
that'd be great jill thank you and then
my second question
is so when i last worked for trafford
which is
ten plus years ago and when i was a
foster carer
schools regularly failed to send
somebody to
the child in need meeting and it's still
happening
even though the meetings are virtual so
we're not having to physically have
the senko or whoever
leave school and go to the meeting and
they're still not even putting in
reports
about their plans to support a child in
need
what can we do to change that so that
they are involved in those meetings
so a couple of things that we're doing
going to know karen will want to come in
from the school
side we we're actually working really
actively as part of the improvement plan
and part of the work that we are doing
in pandemic to really strengthen that
link between
schools and social workers including the
opposite side of it you know schools
will say
well actually you've got a high turnover
rachel in terms of social workers and
what does that look like
um we are um like i say
within our ambitions plan which is our
new improvement plan
because it's right that we don't see
improvements as just related to offstead
it's related to improved outcomes for
our children and it's right that we
should be ambitious for our children
so one of the things that we have
absolutely said is that we want to
collectively
improve our practice in terms of
children in need
because if we're serious about reducing
demand if we're serious about
the best place for children to live and
grow up is in their families
in their communities wherever it's safe
to do so we need to put as much
resource time and energy into our
children in need
um that whole bit about right help right
time
so that is the whole part of our our
ambition plan
in terms of the things that lindsay was
talking about for looked after children
those connectivities between social care
and schools have really been
strengthened
in in the pandemic so we have
liaison teams that include a name social
worker linking into schools
you you won't be surprised to know that
even though we're in pandemic i'm doing
a series of virtual visits to schools
can't wait to be able to actually go on
site and
see some real children not just pictures
of children because that's what it's
what it's all about and i guess that
takes me into the point that i wanted to
make earlier
in in relation to the earlier question
about what would happen
if the welfare officer in the virtual
team wasn't
available for any reason every one of
those 266 looked after children
does have a named allocated social
worker so it's not as if it falls on a
single
person's responsibility so
all of that work and all of that contact
with schools
my new strategic lead for quality
assurance and improvement met with the
all of the primary heads um a week past
friday in terms of saying actually
our our ambitions plan our improvement
activity
is not just about social care what are
we all going to do
together so we're tackling things on an
individual basis if
a social worker hasn't produced the
minutes for the core group or the child
in need meeting
if actually equally we haven't got the
connectivity back in the schools
we will pick it up we're doing much more
of a pincer movement and i think one of
the things that karen would say
is that we are starting to see better
join
um particularly in terms of social care
being responsive and listening to what
schools would say
karen and pamela don't know if either of
you want to come in on that point
i think thank you jill i think just to
reiterate you know that there is a real
desire and a vision now that
that actually we are a single service
across education children's social care
i think probably years gone by
it it it didn't feel like that but i
think we are absolutely ambitious to
achieve that
and and as jill said i think what we've
now done is we've really
set up some real reporting mechanisms
in so schools can connect into children
social care children social care can
connect into schools
and that might be through the
improvement board we've got
representatives from schools on the
improvement board
but equally as jill said the
opportunities for our children's social
care colleagues
to actually directly talk to
safeguarding leads uh cenkos and
and school leaders so i think we've got
some really strong um communication
channels now which i think will improve
practice going forward
that's great thanks karen
did you have a question
is that me
can i ask my question now sure okay
um following on actually from one of the
points that
uh councilman proctor just made i
too was really pleased to see the uh
statement in one of the slides that
special school
staff were getting vaccinations
could i ask just how far down
the the line have we got with that are
we
making good progress or is it still at
the beginning
second one is word of thanks
i made a note in my
little book here asking myself why we
were worried about
students without digital access as they
are specifically able to go to school
thank you for reminding me that some of
those children
can't go to school because they're
shielding
and they're probably ill themselves
so thank you for that and one final one
i was i think it's tragic that
we have a situation where lower and
middle ability students
are being worst hit and are falling
behind in even the basic skills
and i know there's some catch-up funding
being applied
there will that catch up funding be
available to academies
or will it only be for the schools that
are directly
controlled by the local authority
thank you thank you thank you councillor
holden
in terms of the special school
vaccinations that's well underway uh
so they're already we had a meeting
actually with the special school heads
earlier this week to just think uh
reflect on how that's going
uh how it's feeling so that's well
underway lots of staff have been
accessing it over the weekend so
uh naturally the special school heads
have uh i've got that rolled out very
very quickly
uh for obvious reasons so uh that's
that's been really really positive
what we what we have done actually just
interestingly on that point we have
encouraged them to
kind of stage it and phase it a little
bit just in case we end up with a
business continuity issue because if
staff aren't feeling well
then they're not going to be able to
attend work so so we've asked them to
just be careful and consider that as
as as people are accessing their
vaccinations but it's been really really
positive
um so the other question was around
presumably uh the the in terms of the
catch-up funding
um and yes it is it's eligible it comes
in through
three tranches straight into schools so
there's a specific
um model that supplied
a an amount per pupil that is sent
through to schools for them to use as
part of that catch-up funding
and as i said that schools are
responsible for evidencing how that's
how that's supporting the education of
those children who
who require that additional support
thank you i think it you know what was
really and then
deliberately put this in the report
because there aren't any accountability
measures anymore
to to really kind of evidence from a
data perspective
and how our children are are um coping
what was absolutely fantastic was to see
the phonics results because we do have
the phonics check results
uh for our year two children and it was
absolutely fantastic that despite those
children missing a huge chunk of their
education
the outcomes in terms of their phonics
was was really exceptional
and and that's that's just tremendous
and it is really testament to the hard
work of the school
but also the commitment of our families
to really try and support their little
children
um whilst they have been at home
thank you and councillor did you have a
question
yes thank you chair and i would like to
thank thank you for for the
presentations
and the information that have been
provided which was
very comprehensive and i agree with
my counselor colleagues and
wish to thank all staff who work in
education i think
through this pandemic you've worked up
absolutely
brilliantly and uh you know
i think the nation actually
needs to give a you know that kind of
uh gratitude really to to all the work
that has
been done by all staff in schools
um having said that i just want to raise
an issue around the
personal education plan that
was mentioned for our looked after
children
clearly improvements have been made
and i hope that that improvement does
continue because i think personal
education plans
are absolutely critical
in in in terms of the education of those
looked after
children and it's how we actually
do um you know measure
the quality of those personal education
plans because i think it's absolutely
right what lindsay said
in terms of uh quality you know you do
it
it's no use having a personal education
plan if if there's no quality in it
and so so it's how you measure that and
i i did note that
lindsay said it's quite difficult to uh
you know because there's no kind of stun
that standardization around it and
um so i'm i'm interested to know how we
reach
how we know that we've reached equality
uh personal education plan if there's no
sort of standardization around it
so the statutory guidance providing the
education of much better children and
previously looked after children it was
a bit of a framework as to what should
be in a pet
and as i say i've been virtual school
ahead since 2013 and we've kind of
developed the process as we've gone
along
and about three years or so ago and i
set up a northwest group so that we
could all look at each other's quality
assurance processes
and learn from each other and that was a
really useful process we did some
moderation as well where
we've all got different plans as well
there's no standardization in terms of
the plan itself but we all brought our
plans along
we brought along some plans that we
thought were really great and sometimes
that we thought were weaker
so we did some moderation work there so
we're really confident that the quality
assurance tool that we've got now
um is really robust and as i said before
you know it does have very high
expectations particularly the target
setting
because for me the target setting is the
most important bit of the plan
the rest of it is information that's
really important for everybody to gather
and everybody to be aware of but the
targets are really what's going to drive
the improvement forward
so we've done loads of training on
things like outcome focus smart targets
so that you know i remember pep when i
first became virtual school head
and the target was be more confident and
that was what was on the child's plan be
more confident and you know
just how on earth the child would try
and achieve that target there was no
idea about how that would be supported
or how it'd be measured and so we're
very
clear that you know there needs to be
really clear impact measures
we need to be able to see how the pupil
premium funding is being targeted
and to achieve those outcomes as well so
the quality assurance framework that we
have now i'm confident that it is robust
and i'm just excited now to see our
plans
improve and turn by term as we go
forward
if i can just come in on that point
councillor acton
i think lindsay's doing herself and the
team a real disservice
because what she's talking about is some
of the ways that we
measure the the quality against
some of our hard targets and some of our
our quantitative measures
but what lindsay isn't conveying in that
response is the difference that it makes
to individual children
and i know lindsay and the team can tell
lots and lots of stories of how having
a focused plan that helps keep both
schools
social workers and carers
to account that wraps around what is it
we need to do to help this
child this young person to
achieve at a which might include
building confidence but actually how
will we know whether we get there
i know lindsay and her team can tell so
many individual stories
about the difference that they have made
to individual young people
including our our children who have
have been in our care that are now at
university
and how well they're doing at university
how we have supported and helped people
collectively through
the plan so i think when we talk about
our quality assurance processes and our
impact measures
the ultimate impact measure is has it
made a difference to this child and has
it helped them to achieve in aspire to
what they want
and i i am really confident that lindsay
could give you some examples here and
now
and i would love her to but obviously
i'm conscious of time
and so perhaps the next time we come
we can feed better in some of that
qualitative information because
like any part of our improvement journey
the question
has to be so what and what difference
has it made
um but i am really confident that that
the virtual school is cited on that
excellent thank you thank you thank you
so much lindsay i hope
you've enjoyed your first visit to
scrutiny i do hope you'll come and see
us again
um thank you also to um karen
and jill um going to move on to
um agenda item seven which is the
um update on the ofsted um
report and we have jill mcgregor and
pamela wharton here and we also have
um councillor hines so i don't know
who's going to start with this
jill if i start by way of introduction
um
councillor weston and it was really
timely that you said
um it's been a year since we've actually
met as a scrutiny
because it's been a year and one week
since i've been here in trafford
so the last time you met i hadn't even
taken up post
and pamela hadn't taken up post and so
pamela joined us
at the end of october so i think it's
fair to say it's been a year where
there's an awful lot that had
happened and when i was looking at the
minutes and and
um just checking whether we'd done what
we said we would the last time that we
met
one of the things that scrutiny had
asked for was that the heat map that
showed whether we were delivering
against the improvement plan
came back and what i can say is we
haven't brought the heat map back
because we're measuring whether we're
doing what we're saying in a different
way
so we've not only refreshed our
improvement plan to become our eight
ambitions plan
that draws in the strength of the
partnership as well as ownership at
every level
of of the of children's social care
we've linked our ambitions to clear
performance
targets so every one of those eight
ambitions has a set of performance
indicators
and outcome measures to to measure
whether we're being successful
and i know um councillor acton one of
the things that
i hope he would say is that we've done
the same thing to our corporate
parenting work and having
been asking and yourself counselor
western because obviously you come to
corporate parenting
having been asking for well what
difference is it making
how do you know what does it look like
that's one of the areas that we've
really
really drilled down on i think it's fair
to say that
doing improvement work in a pandemic
when your staff and wanting to change
culture
you know you're having to work remotely
it's much more difficult to have hands
all over everything guys on everything
that's doing is
is hugely challenging um but one of the
things that we have done in this last 12
months
is that we have linked our response to
the pandemic
to our improvement activity to say that
actually
if we take everything back to children
if we take everything back to
our young people and our families then
actually
things like hofstede take care of
themselves or we will manage this
collectively in terms of the pandemic
three bits that i would want to really
pull out because there is a lot of
information there
and apologies for there being a lot of
information but it is reflecting that a
lot's happened in the last year really
obviously we've worked hard to
strengthen the leadership and management
team
within children's social care and i
think
um that that in itself means that we can
support our practitioners we can support
managers at every level
um and we can really really start to get
to grip with what we need to improve not
because what
of what ofsted pointed out but because
it's the right thing to do for our
children
karen has already touched on one of the
ways that we're doing that
is that um it's
it's really important to me that we have
a single service approach that we don't
see education as separate from
children's social care
because actually it's really important
that our children do have the
opportunity to aspire and she
achieve they won't be able to do that if
they're not
safe and they're not healthy so actually
bringing those things together has been
a real drive for us in terms of some of
the service
responsibility the other area where i
think we've
really had focus in this last year
is that whole issue about quality
assurance management grip
you can't improve practice if you don't
know what the practice looks like on the
ground
you can't make a difference for children
if you don't understand what their
day-to-day lived
experiences so we've had a massive focus
on
having a quality assurance framework
that actually
has meaning and that managers are
looking at what's happening within their
own teams and understanding what that
means for
individual children we have refreshed
the improvement plan
we've looked at actually what did ofsted
say but what does our data our
performance information
what do our staff what do our children
and families tell us all the big things
that we need to improve
and actually really brought that
together
we've continued to meet as an
improvement board
as karen said we've got a real richness
of representation there so we have our
health colleagues our police colleagues
and we're now in a position where we've
got a secondary head as well as two
primary heads on the improvement
board we have established a whole range
of engagement
mechanisms and i guess critically
in terms of is what we're doing making a
difference i just wanted to highlight
two
quick things that we now have
a majority of case file audits that are
requires improvement
or better and only a small proportion
where the practice has been identified
as not being good enough
we absolutely do have a moderation
process in place so lindsay was talking
about it for the peps
so who checks the checkers who checks
whether those judgments are right
we've now got that moderation process in
place
and we've absolutely gone back to basics
we've gone back to basics to say
in a pandemic one of the first things
that you need to do
is see children because actually going
and visiting children
understanding what's happening for them
having a conversation about what their
worries are
having a conversation with them and
their parents as to why they're not in
school
is the first and most fundamental way
that we understand whether our children
are safe
and last week i was delighted to be
reporting to dfe
that for our children subject to a child
protection plan
a hundred percent of those children had
had a contact
with their social worker and of those
contacts two-thirds of them had been
a face-to-face visit so we were
understanding what was happening for
children we were understanding the
circumstances that they were living in
and that is a very different picture
from when we started our back to basics
approach those of you that know me well
though i like to talk too much
but i don't think it's my turn to to
talk i am going to hand over to pamela
will be able to share some of her
reflections and observations
um in terms of um
progress that we have made in terms of
the plan
and i'm sure that councillor heinz will
want to come in a bit as well
thank you jill yes i this is my first
experience
um i've all been scrutin here so um
thank you for
for having us uh three months i've been
here now so i can't
call myself new but this is my first
time here um and what i can say is it's
absolutely great to be here in trafford
um improvement and children are my
passion
um as i know that they are yours um i've
experienced flooding
and and bomb scares in memphis three
months
in trafford so it's been a steep
learning curve but i
i am really enjoying it um so much
support from
the corporate center i will say because
alongside our
improvement plan we are in the midst of
a redesign of
children's social care and early help
which i think will be crucial
and towards um motoring on
on the improvement journey in terms of
having clarity
of rules and responsibilities um i know
that leadership and
and governance was a key feature of the
offset inspection
and that's the area that i'm leading in
the improvement plan
um and having that clear line of sight
to practice
and managers who are um really clear
about what their role and
responsibilities are
and where and clarity about where
decisions sit
will will be really helped by us having
a clearer structure and
clear schemes a delegation of who can
who can decide what
um i will just say that the um we had a
really positive meeting this week with
our dfe ambassador um and
she's been looking um with practitioners
at a number of cases
she's considered eight cases um in the
last month
and talked to the social worker talk to
the manager
um and and what she's saying is she said
some really good examples
of meaningful direct work with children
that is
improving their outcomes um we still
have a way to go
you'll see from the report that there
are percentages on
audit compilation and compliance we are
not where we need to be in terms of all
managers doing that quality assurance
but we are improving and we are going in
the right direction
we have introduced moderation so
strategic leads and myself
are moderating our managers quality
assurance to get that sense check of
are we all on the same page about
understanding what good looks like
children and but the improvement board
chair was
really positive and and we we have a
program for her to observe
number of meetings number of panels
um as we do with our own chief executive
and
and and member it's great that they're
so involved
um in practice and she
she said that it felt like a different
authority
than the one that she was observing 12
months ago
which is you know it's not down to me
and that's a testament to the hard work
that people have been doing
over the years but i hope what i'm
bringing is
is that equal measure of challenge and
support for people
and clarity about the direction and
under that that vision that that kath
and jill
have about that one service and these
are our children
and it's important that we get them
right and what their
plans for them and their futures right
i'm happy to take any any questions i
don't know cap if you want to add
anything to that
yeah so i think all i would add i mean i
think the
the report um and what yourself and jill
have just articulated do you
give some of the detail um
but i think i'd just like to echo what
what um
what the dfe advisor has said really
that it very much does
feel like um a different authority you
can feel um the the real
um changes that have taken place um
and i think that is very much around
um having that clear line of sight i
think
always it has been the case that um our
social workers and our service
um undoubtedly um have
you know always worked their socks off
and
have always um very clearly cared about
the children in the borough and wanted
the best
for the children in the borough but some
of our ways
of um how we've organized ourselves
really and how we've understood
and fully understood um what our data
means
and having that line of sight on the
quality assurance
and all of those sorts of things the
things that we have worked really really
hard on
um and i don't think you can
underestimate
um you know how intense that's been
really and how
doing all of that and making all of that
change
and through a pandemic and you know has
been incredibly challenging
and i think you um underestimate
actually um pamela you said that's not
down to me
um i think you know you have um you know
you've
really hit the ground running since
you've you've come to trafford
um i think you've had um that you've had
floods and a bomb scare in the last two
weeks never mind since you started with
us
um but i think you know you you you have
um
really settled into uh into life in
trafford and you
absolutely um you know have contributed
to
and to some of the changes that we're
seeing um
and you can't underestimate the impacts
i think that that jill's leadership has
had
as well um it's been um you know it has
been
um really quite phenomenal throughout
this
very challenging time um and one of the
things that i think i
um really observe is the way that people
talk about the
improvement journey um and
very much articulate the the the changes
that we need in terms of
outcomes for children and have always
um in in their minds in our minds really
would this be good enough for
my child and that's a mantra that i
think um
you know is is um really coming through
in
in the culture shift and change really
um
what is it that we want for for our
children how can we
organize ourselves make sure our systems
support the best for our children um
and i think you know once um
we start to you know we started to move
towards
the ambitions that we've got for for
children
and work towards those then the ofsted
improvement journey does take care of
itself actually
and so i just wanted to say thank you
really to everybody who
um you know has contributed so
significant to that journey
are there any questions on the report
who have made such a difference to this
and also to kath of course and everybody
involved um
in the huge amount of work that's gone
into this improvement plan
um nothing else on the agenda other than
to
uh just to note that we will meet again
on the 16th of march i
imagine that would be virtually again um
technology permitting um just one last
thing
um we had a a task and finished group
looking at scnd um exclusions
we just need to have one more meeting of
that task and finish group
um
for that i don't know if people want to
check the diaries to see um their
availability
next week or maybe the week after i know
my diary is filling up very quickly
perhaps um if i suggested a couple of
dates
um and we can sort something out via
email would that be easier for people
okay yeah
in that case thank you all so much for
attending
um particularly to lindsay and pamela
who haven't joined us before i do
hope we've not scared you off and you
will come back and could i wish
everybody
a safe journey back to their sofa or
whichever room they're going into thank
you ever so